dr emma shadalja joins us he's a senior
scholar at the johns hopkins center for
health security
at the bloomberg school of public health
he's in pittsburgh doctor good morning
to you let me
start by talking about the johnson and
johnson vaccine not as effective
as pfizer and moderna but still
effective more importantly
a single dose and as michael noted can
be refrigerated
what do you make of the johnson johnson
vaccine from your standpoint and when do
you think it will be authorized
i think it's a great addition this is a
vaccine as you said that is a single
dose
and it's something that doesn't require
that strenuous cold chain and you have
to remember when you look at these
numbers and try and compare them head to
head
it sort of gives you a little bit of a
misleading picture we were kind of
spoiled by moderna and pfizer having
such high numbers 90
95 percent but the key thing about
johnson johnson
is that it protects you against severe
disease and that's why we're doing this
vaccine
in order to protect people from getting
hospitalized and protect them from dying
i think that you're likely to see it be
submitted for emergency use
authorization in the coming weeks
so it'll take some time before we
actually have this on the shelves and
have the ability to put this into
people's arms
we're hearing a lot about these overseas
of variants
coming over to the united states the
question is the efficacy of our vaccines
do the strains have any impact on them
it depends upon which strain you're
talking about it does appear that our
vaccines are robust against what's
called the uk variant
but there's a little bit of a question
regarding the brazilian variant and the
south african variant but again
as i said before it's really about
preventing severe disease so
what it looks like is the johnson and
johnson and the novovax vaccines
when it comes to the south african
variant maybe protect you
50 60 percent of the time from getting
infected or getting symptoms from the
south african variant
but they're very effective at preventing
you from dying from the south african
or needing hospitalization and again
that's the key thing
so we may have to update our vaccines to
get higher levels of efficacy
but the fact is they do protect you
against what's important severe disease
you mentioned novavax and johnson
johnson we've been talking about
astrazeneca is out there potentially
we once we expand to having more
vaccines available how does that change
the strategy of vaccinations
the strategy will change in that we'll
have a bigger menu we'll have much more
capacity so hopefully
you'll see vaccination clinics be able
to schedule much more farther into the
future
have not as many concerns about supply
and when you're talking about vaccines
like the astrazeneca vaccine the johnson
johnson vaccine that don't require that
same kind of storage requirement
you can get this vaccine closer to
people you can vaccinate for example in
doctors offices or in drug stores where
they don't have access to
a cold chain so it will really make a
major difference in how quickly we can
get vaccine into the arms of americans
and also the world because the johnson
and johnson and astrazeneca vaccines are
important vaccines for the world because
think about how hard it is to maintain a
cold chain
in parts of the developing world where
there isn't access to electricity
until we can get everybody or that
majority vaccinated
we need to worry about masks still and
the cdc has obviously said on mass
transit now they want to see those masks
worn it will be mandatory
what should we know about mass going
forward we've talked a lot in the last
week week and a half about the idea of
wearing two masks also right now
well mass are the simplest way to
prevent spread of this infection and
it's something we should have been doing
better from
from the very beginning there was a lot
of data that we didn't have at the
beginning of the pandemic about the
effectiveness of mass but now it's very
clear
that masking does decrease transmission
but the thing is not every mask is
created equal some people wear flimsy
masks basically trying to check a box to
get into a store they're wearing a
bandana for example
and in that situation it does make sense
to have a multi-layered mask which might
be
achievable if you double up but if
you've got an adequate mask one that's
multi-layered that's kind of
comports with what the cdc has on their
website i don't necessarily think you
have to wear a double mask but
this all really underscores the need to
have standards for the general public
to understand which mass are adequate
which ones are inadequate and i do think
those standards are coming so we will
get better
mass for the general public and it will
be critical because this is the easiest
way
to stop this virus including its
variants from transmitting
dr amish adalga thank you